you're boning Joan let's leave Joan
that's different what if this is gonna
work if I go like this you never know
what's gonna work with movie magic the
background didn't change but like the
the inference from my facial position
you know no usually it should be like
this where I'm coming over here and
you're seeing that I've moved my head
and also the camera change position and
you can see this looks like this angle
prize it's a computer in a window and a
mess a big terrible mess and then I'm
like what I'm back over here that's how
it should work but I don't know if it
works if they just do this I don't know
we're gonna find out when I'm editing
the video all right so there's a lot
stuff going on
first if you're American and everybody
who's not American this doesn't apply to
you if you're an American you need to
sign up at the health care exchange if
you haven't got insurance yet cuz the
deadline is like three days from now and
if you don't sign up you will be fined
because of how you're a drain on society
if you don't know more about that
there's a link in the description VidCon
less than three months away freaking out
this guy right here right now we're
working constantly on content the stuff
that when you go to VidCon you do
time-consuming and terrifying cuz I want
you to have a good time so I spent a lot
of time worrying about it when I say you
I mean people who can go to VidCon I
apologize to everybody who can't I'm I
really am sorry you've just launched
three new channels not just but recently
launched three new channels how to adult
with Mike and Emily a guide to how to
graduate from adolescence without
completely crashing burning which isn't
easy show the art assignment which
actually happened before how to adult
but you've heard of the art assignment
it's a project with PBS and Sarah green
in which we are bringing culture to you
too if anybody ever tells you that
YouTube is a black hole of culture show
them the art assignment or you can just
show them the rest of YouTube cuz it's
it's pretty cool and three launching on
April 1st and no it's not an April
Fool's Day joke I show space
the good space news exploration science
of it takes place not on the planet of
Earth or covering what else ah cellphone
camera tiny nerdfighters for your
packing project for awesome search thank
you guys we just switched over to a
softer shirt style this is an example of
one they're just so much nicer to touch
but that means that we have a bunch of
old shirts that we have to get rid of so
those are back on sale at $10 we moved
warehouse we had a huge sale sold all of
the ones that we thought we were gonna
sell but now we want to sell all of them
so that we can switch to the new shirt
they are on sale for $10 there's a link
in the description so woo and I just
finished my album it's on this if you're
wondering why hold up this hard drive
all I say that 14 songs some of them
you've heard some of them you haven't
with my new band Hank green and the
perfect strangers yes that is the name
of my band I have a band and it is
called Hank ritu the perfect strangers
and it's composed of me Andrew Huang Rob
Scallon and Jodi George I have a band
the album barring unforeseen
circumstances will come out at the end
of April or beginning of March know what
comes after April May I want to make an
internet thing and I'm pretty sure this
is how you do it right you just say I
want to make an internet thing and then
it becomes a thing well I love books and
I love receiving personal
recommendations for books to read thing
called reviews day Tuesday what every
Tuesday you take a picture of a book and
then you review it on your Instagram or
your tumblr your Twitter wherever you
put pictures and words and all that
needs to happen for this to be a thing
is for us to do it and of course there
are lots of other things going on in my
life right now there's crash course
psychology in crash course literature
and an approved and I'm trying to keep
my colon healthy and you know also
maintain a village of several hundred
banished villagers is a video game I'm
talking about right now I'm not saying
it's a bad life I'm just saying I got a
lot going on done I am not comfortable
with any outro aside from I will see you
on Tuesday so I will see you on Tuesday
hi today we're outside the studio of the
artist David Brody this hall with me I
am a solitary
your genius